MALE SPEAKER: But we definitely
plan to implement
Auto Update for the Editor.
The plugin store will have
it built in with no
real work on our part.
But we're going to model it very
much like the Chrome auto
update, where it's sort
of effortless.
It downloads the new version
and asks you
if you want to restart.
Very little work on the user's
part, and you're always kept
up the date with the
latest and the
greatest in the Editor.
The time frame for that is also
soon, but not tomorrow.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Next question,
there was some discussion on
the mailing list about type
inferencing in the Editor.
What is the policy with respect
to untyped variables
and compiler performance?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, we have an
interesting opportunity with
the Editor.
We definitely have to present to
the user the same kinds of
errors and warnings that they
would see running the compiler
or running on the VM
in production mode.
So they'll know what kind of
error they're going to be
looking at.
But we also have the opportunity
to present the
user with additional information
that we can gather
from doing more detailed
analysis than is done,
perhaps, in some other areas.
So we're still looking at
exactly how that's going to
manifest within the Editor and
exactly how we're going to
allow users to control whether
or not they get additional
information.
But that's definitely something
that we can do.
MALE SPEAKER:Yeah, it's
a real balancing act.
We want to be consistent with
the language, its goals, and
allowing people to work
in un-type mode.
But a lot of users really
want the safety and the
scaffolding of types.
And so it's a balancing act of
maybe allowing users who want
to work in more of a type mode
to let the tools, where we can
infer that additional
information, to give them
warnings and help them
work in a safer mode.
And for the developers that
really want un-typed, and
adherence to the language,
that they have
that option as well.
MALE SPEAKER: Right, we also
want to use it to improve the
rest of the editing
experience.
In addition to being able to
potentially provide warnings
about errors that perhaps aren't
specified by the type
annotations.
If you haven't, for example,
haven't provided any.
If you've just declared
everything to be a bar.
But if we can infer the types
of variables, then we can do
additional work for code
completion and refactorings
and other editor functionality
to improve the entire editing
experience.
So it's not just about
errors and warnings.
There's actually a
lot more to it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK, is
SCM Git [INAUDIBLE]
going to be included?
MALE SPEAKER: I think the answer
is, for the editor,
probably not.
But for the plug-in
story, absolutely.
It'll be one of the things
that Eclipse
will give us for free.
And I think obviously team
support SCM Git version is all
extremely important for
working on large scale
projects and working in
professional development
environments and definitely is
something we're going to
support going forward.
FEMALE SPEAKER: When is code
formatting going to be available?
Or is code formatting going
to be available?
MALE SPEAKER: I can take
this unless someone
wants to jump in.
It's on our plate.
It's on our radar.
We have a lot of things on our
plate though, and we've been
prioritizing our work to try
and get the most important
stuff out first.
We use code formatting
heavily internally.
We use it for our review process
to make sure the code
is all normalized so that you
don't deal with a lot of white
space across changes.
And I personally really
like the philosophy
behind the Go Lang.
Where their formatting has
one set of standards.
Their Go Format tool always
formats code the same way.
There's very few preferences
and options.
And I think that when we do
come out with a formatting
tool it'll look similar
to that.
And that it'll format code
according to our code
guidelines, sort of
best practices.
And there will probably be a
command line version of it,
and Editor will probably
use that.
And it'll just work that way.
I think that the time frame is
probably several months out
just based on other things
on our plate.
But it is an open
source project.
So if it's important to you
we're always open to patches.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do you plan
to integrate Run and
Debug menu into one?
Just like in Visual Studio?
Well, it's been a long time
since I've used Visual Studio
so I can't quite recall
how it is.
But if there's any reason that
people are not happy with the
way things are structured right
now, we definitely take
requests and go with it.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I think that
adding a bug to our bug
system, with a little bit more
specificity about what you
want would really help.
We take a lot of our planning
from the bug system feature
requests and current bugs.
And that's really a way to
influence the project for the
Editor, is to file feature
requests and bugs.
MALE SPEAKER: The easiest way
to do that is the Send
Feedback button.
All of those comments and
questions for the Dart Editor,
and for the language in general,
all of those comments
go into our inboxes.
So we see all of them.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Are skeletons,
templates, for
new projects planned?
MALE SPEAKER: We have
some wizards.
We have basically two wizards
for a Hello World web
application and a Hello
World command line.
And I haven't personally given
any thought to more types of
more sophisticated wizards, but
I could see that adding
real value.
So I think, again, file
a feature request and
we'll follow up.
MALE SPEAKER:I suspect we
probably will once we know
what they should look like.
I think it's a little
early yet.
There's a lot of infrastructure
underneath that
hasn't been finalized that will
shape what some of those
templates would look like.
So it's a little bit
hard right now to
provide a final template.
But yeah, I think once we know
what they should look like
we'll do that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Will a rewrite
be done using Dart?
MALE SPEAKER: Well that's
a good question.
That's something we've
speculated about ourselves
every few weeks.
I think the short answer is that
the Dart Editor team's
primary goal is to deliver
fantastic tooling for Dart,
and currently that's
based on Eclipse.
If we were to rewrite in Dart,
it would mean that there would
be a significant period
of time where the
tooling didn't improve.
And I think in the short term
it's safe to say that we're
going to maintain the
Eclipse tooling.
And in the very long term, it's
really anyone's guess.
I think, for a lot of reasons,
it would be fantastic to have
the tooling written in Dart, and
would probably allow the
community to participate
more in the tooling.
But definitely short term,
no, and long term,
it's anybody's guess.
FEMALE SPEAKER: A related
question, will there be a Dart
Web Editor in the Cloud, or
possibly Cloud Nine, support?
Does anybody want
to take that?
MALE SPEAKER: I haven't heard
any concrete plans for that.
I certainly wouldn't rule out
anything like that, because
you never know what we
may end up doing.
The question is, what's most
useful for our users?
That's always what drives us.
That's why the comment earlier,
submit a feature request.
Send feedback.
Let us know what you need from
the tool, because that's what
drives us, is what our
users need most.
And if something like this is
what users need most then
that's where we'll be.
But in the meantime, no we don't
have any immediate plans
to be working on anything
of that nature.
It's also the case that there
may very well be external
people working on it that I
haven't heard about yet.
That would be great.
We would welcome that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: When will you be
able to write Android Apps
using Dart or App Engine Apps?
MALE SPEAKER: So this question,
or a very similar
one, came up yesterday with Seth
and JJ and [INAUDIBLE].
And the short answer is that we
have had requests for App
Engine support, and it makes
sense in our context.
But there's no announcements
in that area.
And for Android Apps, Android,
the browser obviously is a
modern browser.
And Dart is targeting modern
browsers as its platform.
And we want to make Dart run
fantastically on all those
especially, and including,
mobile devices.
Native support is not something
on our radar
currently, but definitely
fantastic mobile apps are.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK, a
language question.
Will Dart have annotations?
MALE SPEAKER: OK, I'll
take this one.
If you look on the Issue Tracker
you can see that Galad
has actually talked
about this.
Annotations make a lot
of sense for Dart.
It's not going to happen as a
first class language feature
in the short term.
It's going to be a ways out.
The Editor has specific needs
for some smaller subset of
annotations, and we will
probably add some extra
lingual features for that-- so
some structured comments--
to allow you to indicate that a
method that you're using or
have defined is deprecated.
That possibly methods
that you're using
override parent methods.
So if you do refactoring, and
you think you're overriding
something, you're not,
you get a warning.
And because we're going to be
creating additional warnings
that are not part of the
language specification but
that add value to users, like
unused fields, we want a way
to disable those warnings in
specific places in code.
Because maybe that warning is
true in the general case, adds
value, but in specific
cases you don't want
to know about it.
So we'll have some extra lingual
annotation support,
which will probably go away
once Dart has first class
annotations.
Brian, does that sound like
the general answer?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I can't
think of anything to add.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK, I think
we're done with
the specific questions.
There's a general question.
What are some upcoming
features?
Maybe you can talk about some
features that the questions
didn't reference.
MALE SPEAKER: Absolutely, one
of you two want to take the
Type Hierarchy?
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: So we've had a lot
of requests for our Type
Hierarchy View.
Which probably people coming
from more structured languages
really like seeing the
inherent hierarchy.
Myself, I use it all the time
for navigating code.
That's something that
we're missing
in the Editor currently.
I can see that being added
in the near term.
Not immediately, but definitely
having a way to
view your parent classes and
child classes of what you're
currently editing.
It'd be super useful.
For myself and [INAUDIBLE],
working on the debugger, we
have some plans in that area.
Short term, we want to just add
some small features and
bug fixing.
There are pretty
good debuggers.
You get a full source level
debugger when you're running
against Dartium.
But there's some areas
for improvement.
Long term, we want to have
better, tighter, coupling with
the Virtual Machine.
So that when you make
modifications in your code
that's reflected in the
Virtual Machine.
One second.
Sorry, I thought that was the
Moderator telling me I had
reached my time limit.
But, yeah so when you're
debugging you could modify
fields and have those changes
reflected live, and very
sophisticated debugging
features.
We're not close to that now.
That something that's a
long term goal for us.
That requires support from the
virtual machine, and the
virtual machine team has a lot
of demands on their time.
It'll be something that we
will allow eventually--
having much, much tighter
coupling and awareness of the
virtual machine.
Another aspect of debugging
is our JavaScript story.
Currently you have very first
class support when you're
running your Dart application
natively in Dartium.
And that's a great development
story.
But right now, for deployment,
you often have to target
browsers which do not support
Dart natively.
So you compile your Dart code
to Javascript using
Dart-to-JS.
We want the Editor
to provide better
support for those scenarios.
And that may not include full
source level debugging for
your Dart compiled
to JavaScript.
But we want to improve the story
somewhat so you can get
console logging back.
You can get exceptions back.
And you just have a better
experience, even if it's not
quite the experience of
developing against Dartium.
What other features do
we have on the plate?
FEMALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
you want to say something?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, we have a
number of smaller features.
Some of the ones that are
probably more interesting--
doing some work in the Quick
Assist area or Quick Fixes.
If you're familiar with what
Eclipse has, I expect we'll be
doing something along those
lines fairly soon to help
resolve compilation errors and
other issues that pop up.
We've also had a lot of requests
for being able to
control the visual appearance
of the Editor.
Being able to do theming
of various kinds.
And I expect we'll be doing
something along
those lines as well.
We've already got some starting
in terms of being
able to set the font size.
MALE SPEAKER: And some
key binding.
key binding changes.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: It
is interesting.
A lot of small aspects of the
development environment are
really important to people.
Being able to change your key
bindings is just a continual
source of frustration
if you can't do it.
It doesn't take us a lot of work
to do, but some things
have a big impact
on usability.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
definitely.
We talked about some earlier.
Definitely we want to work on
improving the type inferencing
that we have.
Right now we have a very
small start at it.
There's a lot of work that we
can do to improve that, which
will have a big impact on a
lot of Editor features.
Like we said, code completion
and refactoring and a number
of other areas.
MALE SPEAKER: You want to talk
about the Analysis Engine?
MALE SPEAKER: That's part of
the type inferencing stuff.
The other major thing coming up
in that area, we have some
plans for ways to significantly
improve the
performance.
Which, if those pan out, should
help with the Editor
experience quite a bit.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK, we
have a new question.
But I'm not sure how well we
would be able to answer it.
What is the plan for Dart
on mobile devices?
Standalone VM?
Built-in Browser?
Browser Extension?
MALE SPEAKER: I don't have
knowledge of that myself.
So my guess would be the current
plan is to support it
using Dart-to-JS.
And like any sort of modern
browser, if it supports HTML
5, then we want to run
on that platform.
MALE SPEAKER: I know there is
a lot of interest in being
able to support mobile
devices.
But I don't believe that we
have any concrete plans at
this point for exactly how
that's going to work.
Definitely supporting JavaScript
on any of the
modern browsers.
But as far as native work, I
know that's a great interest.
But I haven't heard any concrete
plans for exactly how
that's going to happen.
Whether we're going to put the
VM on the platform, or whether
there's going to be some other
mechanism for doing that.
MALE SPEAKER: And the nice thing
about the Dart project
is that most of what
you see happens.
It's totally open source.
Our development is
open source.
All of our code reviews
and our commits.
And mostly the future of the
platform is there for you to
see in the commit logs.
It's very open in that sense.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK,
another question.
Running Dart code on VM is quite
open source in nature.
It's not obfuscated.
Is there any plans to give
developers build in box way to
make it at least not easy
to copy and paste code?
MALE SPEAKER: That's
a good question.
I'm not aware of that myself,
an obfuscation tool.
It may be something that we
don't provide but that is
provided by a third party, like
people in the Java world.
We will have a tool that will
take your Dart code spread out
over several hundred source
files, and consolidate it into
one file for deployment.
That'll make the start up of
your web application quicker.
The goal of that won't
necessarily be obfuscation so
much as small code size.
Are we out of questions?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yes, we're done
with all the questions.
MALE SPEAKER: All right, well
thank you for watching.
And I'd encourage everyone to
visit the dartlang.org website
for more information
about Dart and to
download the Editor.
And if you're at Google IO,
definitely see the sessions
that we have and Jamie's
Code Lab.
MALE SPEAKER: See
everyone at IO.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
all for watching.